S
SHE'S DOING.
WHY DID SHE FLOP, GREG?
>> I MEAN, FIRST OF ALL, $80 PER
THEATRE.
I'VE MADE $80 IN A THEATRE AND
THERE WASN'T EVEN A MOVIE
PLAYING.
>> WOW.
WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
THE IT'S NO SURPRISE, WHO WOULD
GO SEE A MOVIE THAT'S THE
OPPOSITE OF ENTERTAINING.
THERE'S NOTHING ENTERTAINING
ABOUT THAT.
MICHAEL MOORE'S COLONOSCOPY IS
MORE ENTERTAINING THAT, BECAUSE
THERE'S PROBABLY MORE TWISTS.
SHE DOES DO HER JOB, RIGHT?
SHE MAKES MOVIES.
SHE GOES TO GALAS.
SHE SITS FOR GLOSSY BUTT-KISSING
INTERVIEWS IN GQ AND OTHER
WOMEN'S MAGS.
ONCE YOU GET OVER THE FACT
YOU'RE HOLLOW INSIDE, IT'S NOT A
BAD LIFE.
>> DANA?
>> I READ "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
REVIEW, AND TEO THINKS THAT THE
HOPELESSNESS OF THE MOVIE MAKES
IT A HARD SELL FOR PEOPLE TO SEE
THE MOVIE AND FOR VOTERS TO
CHANGE THEIR MINDS ABOUT CLIMATE
CHANGE.
THEY SAID FOR AOC, SHE OFFERS
THE BEST ON-SCREEN ANTIDOTE TO
DESPAIR BECAUSE SHE'S FUNNY.
THEY DON'T LIKE IT IF
CONSERVATIVES ARE FUNNY.
>> IF A CONSERVATIVE IS FUNNY,
YOU'RE BEING MEAN.
>> I'M FASCINATED THERE WAS AN
AUDIENCE FOR THIS OUTSIDE OF
EARTH JUSTICE, THE JUSTICE
DEMOCRATS, BECAUSE WHO WANTED TO
GO AND SEE THIS THING.
TOMORROW YOU'LL HAVE AN ARTICLE
THAT WE HAVE TO TALK ABOUT,
WHICH IS THAT KIDS ALL OVER
AMERICA ARE HAVING NIGHTMARE
ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE.
NO WONDER.
>> JESSICA, WHAT ABOUT THE FACT
THAT THE CLIMATE ACTIVISTS ARE
VERY MUCH -- I MEAN, ARE
ENTHUSED ABOUT WHAT THEY DO, AND
THEY DO ALL KINDS OF THINGS TO
GET ATTENTION.
THEY'RE WILLING TO GET RUN OVER
ON THE HIGHWAYS, GET THEIR SKIN
GLUED IN MUSEUMS.
WHY AREN'T THEY AT LEAST
WATCHING A MOVIE?
>> THEY'RE CHEAP.
>> PEOPLE DON'T GO TO THE
THEATRE ANYMORE.
I MEAN, THEY DO FOR "TOP GUN" OR
THE MARVEL MOVIES THAT ARE
SUCCESSFUL.
CERTAINLY IN THE POST-COVID ERA,
EVERYONE WANTS TO WATCH
SOMETHING AT HOME, ESPECIALLY
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
THERE WAS A NETFLIX DOCUMENTARY
SHE HAD, CALLED "KNOCK DOWN THE
HOUSE," AND THAT WAS HIGHLY
VIEWED, BECAUSE PEOPLE COULD SIT
AND WATCH IT, GRAB DINNER, COME
BACK, TURN IT BACK ON.
THE MOST SUCCESSFUL CLIMATE
DOCUMENTARY WAS AL GORE'S
$INCONVENIENT TRUTH, AND ONLY
MADE $24 MILLION.
>> DEBUTED ON THE COLDEST DAY OF
THE YEAR.
>> WOULD YOU GO TO THIS MOVIE?
>> NO.
WILL I TALK ABOUT IT?
YES.
AS A PRODUCT IN THE MARKETPLACE,
AOC, NO ONE WANTS TO BUY THAT.
>> YEAH.
>> SO THIS IS WHAT POLITICIANS
OFTEN GET CONFUSED ABOUT.
JUST BECAUSE YOU'RE POPULAR IN
POLITICS DOESN'T MEAN YOU'RE
POPULAR ANYWHERE ELSE.
IN FACT, USUALLY PEOPLE THAT
CAN'T DO ANYTHING ANYWHERE ELSE
GO INTO POLITICS TO SUCCEED.
SHE FOUND OUT THAT WAY, THE HARD
WAY.
WHAT'S FRAUDULENT ABOUT THIS,
BECAUSE SHE'S TRYING TO SELL
HERSELF AS SOME HIKER.
WHERE DID SHE GROW UP AGAIN?
WESTCHESTER.
SHE REPRESENTS QUEENS.
SHE WEARS PLAID AND HAS LITTLE
SKI THINGS WITH A 60-POUND
BACKPACK.
LIKE SHE DOES THAT?
SHE SHOW CAUSES HER WHOLE LIFE
ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
YOU CAN NEVER SEE HER IN
PRIVATE.
EVERYTHING IS ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
I'VE NEVER SEEN HER HIKE BEFORE.
THE ONE TIME SHE DOE